a major medical journal published a
peer-reviewed
research article last month on an urgent
disease that scientists say
we need to stop i'm not talking about
the wuflu the kung flu the lung past
second not that
i am talking i kid you not about
whiteness which the author dr donald
moss describes as
parasitic and for which he hopes to find
a quote permanent cure
a major anti-trump narrative falls apart
kamala harris's propaganda falls flat in
guatemala
we do not have the cure to whiteness on
this show but we do have the cure to
fake news
whiteness as a parasitic
disease for which we must find a
permanent cure a permanent what's a
what's another term for permanent cure
you might say a permanent cure would be
like a
i don't know like a final solution you
know or some i don't how do you cure
whiteness
how do you cure it well there there's
only one way to do that and it's
pretty ghastly this is what this doctor
donald moss
says in the article on having whiteness
quote
parasitic whiteness renders its hosts
appetites voracious
insatiable and perverse these deformed
appetites particularly target
non-white peoples once established these
appetites are nearly impossible to
eliminate
effective treatment consists of a
combination of psychic and social
historical interventions
such interventions can reasonably aim
only to reshape
whiteness's infiltrated appetites to
reduce their intensity
redistribute their aims and occasionally
turn those aims toward the work of
reparations
when remembered and represented uh the
ravages
wreaked but reeked or wrought this guy
he's not the brightest bulb in the pack
the ravages reeked
by the chronic condition can function
either as
warning never again or as temptation
great again memorialization alone
therefore is no
guarantee against regression there is
not yet a permanent cure okay when i
first read this i assumed it was satire
i assumed he was joking and showing how
crazy this anti-white
ideology has become the anti-white
ideology embodied
now most notably by critical race theory
but by all sorts of
leftist ideologies that developed over
the last century but i think he's
serious
i think he's serious about this of
course it is
cliche and tedious and ridiculous to say
imagine if the situation were reversed
imagine if someone published an article
about how black people are evil and that
we need a permanent cure and how they
specifically target non-uh they
specifically target white people and all
this sort of thing
uh that that would be you you would be
run out of town on a rail i mean you'd
be basically
booted from the country you'd probably
end up in a terror watch list or
something
but this sort of thing is presented in a
major medical journal peer review i mean
i don't i don't think peer review means
anything at all i think it's a complete
farce
but people seem to have some respect for
it well this is an article in a
respectable journal saying that that
white people are evil and they tell us
by the way
on the left that uh this is delusional
you know there are all these sorts of
theories out there over the what this is
all really about is this ideological is
this sexual
is this uh racial what where where is
the politics really hinging right now
and this guy's answer is obviously
the racial answer he's saying he is
saying and
and there have been plenty of people who
have claimed this and then the left
comes in and says you're all kooks and
conspiracy theorists
this guy is saying we hate you because
you're white and we want to get rid of
all the white people right that's what
he's saying
the issue of racial consciousness here
is a really strange one
because whites uniquely
don't have a racial consciousness you
can see pew
research did a survey about this a few
years ago a survey of
different racial groups and ask them is
your race
very important or somewhat important to
your identity and for every single
racial group
more than 50 of people said yes it is
except for white people
so for every group it was greater than
50 for black people it was greater than
70
for white people that number was just 15
so whites do not have a racial
consciousness i don't think of things
generally in racial terms i think i
guess i'm a white person so there it is
am i a white person i don't know i'm a
little swarthy but
i suppose i would be classified that way
i don't think of things that way i think
of things
in philosophical terms religious terms
ideological terms maybe geographic terms
but race is pretty low on the list and
yet
this guy is coming out and he's
he's not attacking people because
they're conservative
he's not he's attacking trump supporters
right he says great again but he's not
attacking them specifically because
they're trump supporters
he's not attacking them because they're
christian he's not attacking them
because they're american he is attacking
them because
they are white and the simple fact is
that the more this ideology progresses
you will see an intensification of white
racial consciousness there's just no
alternative to that
you cannot have a political regime in
which every single group
is told to think primarily if not
exclusively about their race
and in which only one racial group can
be castigated can
can have calls for genocide in a major
medical journal
and not have that racial consciousness
increase
i don't think this is good for politics
i don't think that
a heightening of racial consciousness
and i think inevitably racial tension
is good for for american politics
but in political battles your opponents
get a say
and the opponents are very clear here
the left by the way i think this
doctor's a white guy
not positive i think he is though the
name like donald moss he doesn't he
sounds like a guy from like oregon or
something you know
a guy who has like a thin beard and
wears lots of
like thin flannel that's just the image
in my mind
this guy is saying we are going to
fight political battles on racial
grounds and so we conservatives can say
okay well we don't want to do that
but the left gets to say too and the
left has made its decision
if you do not ring that bell subscribe
to this
video then youtube will render me
speechless which is coincidentally the
name of my upcoming book it's going to
be released in 11 days speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is available now for pre-order
you got to get those notifications you
got to make sure you don't miss a video
and head on over to apple podcast google
play stitcher spotify
gmail hotmail aol instant messenger
subscribe to the michael knowles show
audio podcast leave a five star review
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]